le comprends pas du tout la position de
l'uefa je ne la comprends pas je ne la
supporte pas pourquoi parce que ça fait
quelques années qu'il ya plusieurs
fléaux dans le sport dont le racisme
dont l'homophobie et que l'uefa
comme beaucoup de fédérations
internationales du sport font les
efforts pour lutter contre ces fléaux et
que parce que on serait dans une ville
où il ya certains pays qui va jouer on
n'arborait pas certaines couleurs
manuel neuer a le brassard de capitaine
allemand avec le brassard torrentielles
depuis le début de la compétition il n'a
pas attendu la hongrie de jeu et de
hongrie pour l'arborer toutes les villes
toutes les fédérations de football à
rebours ce drapeau aujourd'hui à arc en
ciel est donc en fonction des
circonstances à vous à dire qu'on va
plus ou moins timides ou francs sur le
fait de défendre des valeurs
fondamentales passe assez
incompréhensible donc ce que ça fait là
l'uefa dans ce cas là est antinomique
avec ce qu'elle prétend défendre
d'habitude
[Musique]